vraiment un moment inoubliable dans tpm
quand on est parti à las vegas avec
toute l'équipe et qu'on a passé quatre
cinq jours tous ensemble justin asmar et
à préparer ce faux mariage bien sûr iam
c'est ouais mais franchement il ya eu ce
qui a été diffusé
non j'avais regardé tout ce qui t'est
rossiter égalé mais si vous savez tout
ce qu'on n'a pas diffusé il y aurait de
quoi faire sans trop de prime donc je
pense que je pense que c'est ça c'est le
voyage à las vegas fait exceptionnel
mon petit roman j'irai séjour à las
vegas parce que dans tous cas pas été
diffusé il ya de bonnes raisons qui ont
fait que ce soit très diffusé
[Musique]